asking retired by the questions we
really want to know what are your
thoughts on the situation in ukraine
well we knew it was coming and when it
was going to happen you spent plenty of
time in russia during your spying days
do you have any further insights
i would say we just look back at uh
historical russian invasion of
afghanistan a lot of parallels there
what type of spy were you
i was russian cryptological linguist
will this start world war three
that will probably depend on
us curbing our bellicosity what points
while being a spy were you the most
scared
during the classified portions of my
training do you cover the camera on your
laptop
yes
how much longer do you think our
democracy will last
probably only a couple more election
cycles what will lead to humanity's
destruction
sophistry how would you define sophistry
in your own words
lying to prove a point i think the world
will look like after cobid
well i don't think there is
[Music]
i mean it took a long time he never lied
to me he just he just never told me
because i knew he was in the military
and i always joked with him i always
like oh you're a spy like that explains
why you know russian always told me no i
was a weatherman and a bus driver but he
never elaborated off of that junior year
parent teacher conference and my teacher
asked him what he did in the military
and he said oh weatherman
and my teacher said oh wow that sounds
like a really good cover up for a spy
and my dad said oh yeah i guess i did
that you know too at the beginning
and i went
what people want you to speak russian
with your texas accent
people should do when world war 3 breaks
out
make sure they have plenty of cash on
hand because things tend to fall apart
if you were to customize your ideal home
what is the top security feature you
would implement
steel bowlers i think is the biggest
reason for our democratic backsliding
gerrymandering and political apathy
what do you mean by political apathy
too many people are falling for softest
dream becoming disillusioned
do you have any tips for decoding
messages
well a strong cipher typically uses both
diagonal and inverted to hashes were the
residences you were staying at in russia
bugged
everywhere was bugged
are pen and paper communications more
secure than electronic communications
not necessarily do you have any enemies
probably
what are your thoughts on afghanistan
the taliban will soon take over again
and it'll be chaos just like syria what
would it take for you to release
classified information
wouldn't happen
you